all right to the extent that anyone
thinks that bill o'brien was fired
because he traded deandre hopkins
cal mcnair the owner of the team made it
clear yesterday that
hopkins didn't fit the overall financial
structure they have a franchise left
tackle that they had to pay and he's
performing at a high level they have a
franchise quarterback they had to pay
and at some point you just can't pay
everybody right you don't have any money
left and that's what mcnair said he
easily could have said i had misgivings
about trading deandre hopkins but i gave
bill o'brien the benefit of the doubt
now i realize given that hopkins has 100
catches in four games then maybe i
shouldn't have done it could have said
that didn't no he made it clear right he
was on board with it yeah he was on
board with the move to trade deandre
hopkins so whatever the reason that bill
o'brien was fired it wasn't because he
traded deandre hopkins no i i would hope
not i mean that's something we tried to
talk sense into people right back in the
spring it wasn't about like
oh i'm trading this guy because i think
he's falling off or falling out you know
down a cliff as a player or anything
like that it was to it was a strictly a
money situation they knew he wanted more
money they knew they were about to gonna
pay desean watson soon and at that time
too i think they were still figuring out
the laramie tunzel deal where he became
the highest paid left tackle in the
sport you know there's only so many
people you can pay top dollar to you
know when you start to do that you'll
start to dance into atlanta falcons area
where it's like hey we paid five guys
like 50 of the salary cap and now yeah
when we get two injured like our team
falls apart so you can't do that it's
just very hard to balance that to go oh
receiver you know top two or three
highest in the football left tackle
highest in football quarterback he is
the highest in football now right i mean
how many record holders can you have on
the team to do that that's not going to
be a good formula you don't see really
other good teams that are successful
consistently have that the patriots
don't have three guys that are leading
the market at their position and other
great teams like that are not doing that
so uh yeah this is just something they
had to move the time had come and they
knew they couldn't spend that money on
him
yeah i agree with you completely and
look i don't know what the story
ultimately is on why bill o'brien is out
but the the ideas and the theories and
the hypotheses that have been suggested
to date have yet to really hit the mark
for me and i just don't understand how
four games of performances general
manager brings down six plus years of
performance as a head coach and again
it's look he's not headed to the hall of
fame for what he did in houston but he
was the best coach they ever had from
the standpoint of getting to the
playoffs and winning playoff games yeah
they've only had three right they had
dom capers gary kubiak and uh and bill
o'brien's right that's it since 2002. so
they may they may if they don't get this
one right they're gonna have more than
three over the next five or six years
because it's going to become the
revolving door but they've got desean
watson and that should give them the
weapon that they need in their arsenal
to get a great coach who's going to want
to go there as long as that coach is
comfortable with the power structure and
what's expected of him who he reports to
and whether or not he's comfortable
deferring any authority any power any
say so to somebody who just who just uh
isn't qualified frankly to chime in on
matters related to the operation of of
the football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports